hi there steve kaufman here uh today i'm
going to talk a bit about uh teach
yourself
and specifically teach yourself romanian
i'm going to compare it a little bit to
the pimsleur pimpster romanian
and
talk a little bit about what i've been
listening to on my ipod nano
using my new
bluetooth
earphones which are very handy
so uh last video i talked about pimsleur
and i said that um
pimsleur you know for me because i'm not
so keen to be prompted to speak
i don't respond to their prompts to
speak in other words in pimps or what
they do is they give you a a simple
dialogue and they break it down
and then they ask you a question which
you should reply to in romanian in the
target language but i started two weeks
ago so it's a little bit early for me to
try and say anything in romanian
so to me pimpster is primarily a source
of
repeatedly listening to certain phrases
phrases that they have decided are
important for me like
um do you understand romanian i
understand romanian where is the
restaurant it's on this street where is
the hotel are you do you want to have
dinner with me do you want to have a
drink with me more or less that seemed
to be everything you know just going
from memory
so
uh
never mind that i started on romanian
about 10 days ago and i started the
minute we had launched romanian at link
uh
because i'm going to romania and june
for three days so
you know we got romanian i want to learn
romanian so i decided to start
we didn't have any content in the link
library so i went around looking in the
bookstores i found pimpster so i started
on pimsleur and i essentially listened
to it mostly in the car
but i went to the library i had an old
copy of of teach yourself romanian plus
i went to the library and they had the
cds for it so i've gone through the
teach yourself romanian so
what do i think of it well
it has a lot of advantages and some
disadvantages compared to pimsleur
the advantage is that it introduces an
awful lot more vocabulary lots there's
20 chapters
uh i guess two or so of them are
recapitulare which means to um
to review
but other than that each one of them
introduces at least 20 or so new items
of vocabulary
that's good
the other thing that's good is that they
introduce different aspects of the
grammar with lots of examples so rather
than just explanations they'll have a an
introduction and then they have lots of
examples
and so i find it very useful to read
these examples i don't know whether they
stick or don't stick i mean you have to
read these things over and over again
i'm reading the book now for about the
third or fourth
time reading some of the same examples
reading the dialogues going over the
vocabulary list all those things so to
that extent i'm willing to spend more
time on on teach yourself
than on pimster because at any rate if i
have dedicated time i'm going to read
i'm not going to listen that's just how
i learn
uh plus i took the cd from the pimsleur
and i've listened to it a few times now
some of the dialogues are still a bit of
a blur
the disadvantage oh and one thing that i
don't like about teach yourself is that
there is a fair amount of english
button they don't
similar to pimpster but the big
difference between pimsleur and teach
yourself is
that teach yourself the sound is not as
clear
the clearest sound on the teach yourself
is the british guy who's explaining
stuff to you
some of the romanian speakers are clear
some are quite unclear
some of the dialogues have you you're
supposed supposedly it's a phone call so
you hear the phone dial
and one of the voices is kind of
obscured because it's coming out of a
telephone so they do things to make the
sound less clear
plus some of the voices are not clear
and i experienced this with my czech
teacher self they had one voice there
that was so soft and unclear it was
too annoying to listen to the big
advantage of pimpster is the romanian
comes booming through very clear and i
think it's very important for a beginner
to hear the language very clearly
so to that extent as i said pimster is a
good icebreaker pimsleur is a better
icebreaker than teach yourself pimsleur
kind of gets you wrapped up to where the
at least some aspects of the language
don't sound so strange so then when you
hit them and teach yourself i think
you've already got a bit of of momentum
and i think it is good to use a variety
of different systems uh people ask me
what i think of michelle thomas well i
listen to it a little bit personally i
can't i don't like that format where he
has these two students saying things
incorrectly but for people who like that
it's also undoubtedly a good icebreaker
so people who do michelle thomas
in my opinion should also do teach
yourself because it's a different
approach with more of explanations more
examples and stuff like that but the
sound quality in the teach yourself is
not nearly as good as in pimsleur
um other than that i'm enjoying it the
other thing about
about a book like pimsleur or excuse me
a system like pimsleur or teach yourself
they have lots of different dialogues
and things of that nature
uh which they try to make interesting
but they aren't really very interesting
at all
so to the extent
that the dialogues aren't interesting it
doesn't really matter what
it's just language in the initial stages
as you're trying to get used to it so
what i did finally
was that i uh
wrote out
uh about um
20 odd sort of what i call patterns
uh in english so that using you know
greetings and using
why where when
because in order to although
since you know and then for each one of
these i'd have six example sentences in
english which i recorded in english by
the way and put into link for
those people who are starting with
english at links but then i went through
elance
on the internet and found someone in
romania to translate those
20 times
or 20
probably 24 times six sentences
into romanian and then to record them
for me and there was a bit of back and
forth to improve the sound quality and
when they were finally done i imported
them into link
and so now i have these
clear
phrases and sentences of things that i'm
interested in learning in romanian
which i listen to over and over again
and then i read them
on link and save the words that i need
this is the other you know disadvantage
of
for me in learning say from vocabulary
lists
in
say teach yourself it doesn't work as
well for me as when i can read them on
link and see the yellow highlighting and
have flash cards and so forth and so on
and which also enables me to review
those lessons on my ipad on my iphone
wherever i am and so forth and so on
so
i did that plus
and that's why i repeat it's i think
it's so good to do
sort of go at things from different
directions
i found uh radio romania radio romania
romania i don't know romania
and
there
there you can download podcasts of the
news
which of course
don't really understand although there's
a lot of words that sound very similar
to italian but then they have
little articles so i can import those
articles save the words that i need
and i have this impression that
uh
70 of the words in romanian are words
that i already know from other romance
languages another
20 percent are were some perc surprising
number are words that i know from slavic
languages and then there's all the
connecting words why because now since
and some of the idiosyncrasies of the
romanian grammar that i have to learn
but it's going to be a lot faster and so
now if i read a news article on the
radio romania website
i understand it basically it's i
understand it better than
than korean that's for sure
after having done
russian and czech and korean boy this
romanian is is really quite
a piece of cake i think although how
well i'll be able to speak remains to be
seen but insofar as understanding it
it's certainly going very very quickly
so i have all those different things on
the go i don't think i'm going to listen
to my pimsleur again because it's just
it's just too limited the vocabulary
it's too boring to hear over and over
again i'm still going to listen to my
teach yourself and review some of the
lessons there because there's still
words that i don't pick up when i listen
uh and there's still grammar patterns
that i need to review in order to have
them sink in
i will be sending more patterns in
english to my
romanian friend who will record them for
me so that i can continue to work on
some basic patterns based on what i feel
i need to have
and i'm hoping that over time
as i read more and more of the articles
on radio romania that i'll be able to
understand more and more of the news
reports
because these articles are not the sort
of transcript of the
audio but obviously the vocabulary is
going to be more or less it'll reappear
in the articles and in the in the
recording so that's kind of going to be
my strategy
and i am going to start speaking with my
tutor in romania
uh this week uh which is for me is
completely uh out of the norm the norm
is that i'll go six months without
speaking to anyone but i don't have the
luxury because i'm going to be in
romania uh for three days in early june
and so i'm going to start struggling to
speak here and of course the fact that
70 of the vocabulary i already have from
italian and so forth is going to make it
easier nevertheless i don't know how my
first
romanian encounter is going to go but
but we shall see so anyway i guess the
conclusion in all of this is don't be
afraid to use a variety of different
systems
to uh to work on your language skills
and they all have the roles i think
pimpster is a good icebreaker
teach yourself introduces some of the
basic grammatical concepts and then i
know from experience i need an awful lot
of exposure and so i'm just going to be
listening and reading and and gradually
letting my brain get
used to the language get used to the
patterns occasionally review them in my
teach yourself book uh as i say i don't
think the pimps the pimsleur has served
its purpose as an icebreaker i don't
think i'll be going back there
um
because it just simply takes too long to
get the vocabulary that you need
um and i'm going to start speaking much
much earlier than i normally do
so there you have it a bit of a review
of pimpster and teach yourself some
suggestions of how to break into a
language particularly one where there's
a lot of common vocabulary and i would
maybe close by saying that i think in
language learning the biggest obstacle
is the vocabulary and the
closer or the more common vocabulary
there is the easier it's going to be to
learn
and um
with romanian i think that gives me a
big advantage
so i'm going to do that and then i'll go
back to korean once i come back from
from romania okay thank you for
listening bye for now